in the book you write about a very
traumatic experience in your in your
life you want you have surgery is this
my cosmetic surgery for your head I had
hair plug surgery okay I'm what I am
willing to admit here on your show okay
and I've done it for the last couple of
weeks that I had hair transplant surgeon
okay a lot of people do that in this
business but you had a side effect what
was I did well when I was under the
first six I got which were like akin to
torture I did with a local anesthetic
which involves needles going into your
scalp and then you can hear the medicine
come out of the needles inside your head
and one day the doctor is like you know
you can get this under a general
anesthetic you can go under which I did
and they put a tube down my throat and
then it's sat on the laryngeal nerve
which is responsible for firing my left
vocal cord and when I woke up I sounded
like this I couldn't talk louder than
this for nine months nine months this is
how you make your living I thought it
was I mean I thought it was over I was
going through tough time personally I
was going through divorce I I mean I
jumped on antidepressants as fast as I
could find them and a lot changed in my
life but I got through it I didn't miss
any games but it was at outis did people
notice oh yeah your voice will noticed
and those same people on Twitter that
probably did those pictures are like
good I hope he's dying but I didn't die
damn it I'm here to call golf I should
have been
if it ever happens again I can call golf
for the rest I live because I had a
purpose to call gold right and that
holds I know your hair looks good yeah
luscious luscious in the in the in the
book you have this there's this great
moment where you're going through this
tough time you've had the hair plugs put
in but you lost your voice and you run
into Matthew McConaughey of all people I
did you confess to him I confess to him
and maybe I was fishing for information
if maybe possibly he had gone through
something like I had gone through yeah
not with the voice but with the other
part and I said so I I had this hair
surgery and now I whispering I was like
now I can't talk and he took him in and
he's like so what you're saying buckaroo
is you fixed your video but you screwed
up your audio like hey and I bought
three Lincoln's yeah
[Laughter]
a whole head of hair
you